investigators say they may never know
who provided prince with a counterfeit
drugs that caused his death a minnesota
prosecutor said yesterday that no
charges will be filed in the death of
the music icon
two years ago he accidentally overdosed
on fentanyl Jamie yuccas is at Prince's
Paisley Park Estate that's outside
Minneapolis Jamie good morning good
morning prosecutors released a trove of
pictures and videos that show the
singers final days along with his
struggle with painkillers investigators
say there is no evidence to suggest that
the drugs prince took were prescribed by
a doctor the bottom line is that we
simply do not have sufficient evidence
to charge anyone with a crime related to
Prince's death Carver County Prosecutor
mark met says it's unclear how Prince
obtained the counterfeit vicodin laced
with fentanyl which led to his death
investigators released video recorded
inside Paisley Park the day Prince died
pill bottles were recovered from
multiple parts of the mansion there is
no evidence that any person associated
with Prince knew Prince possessed any
counterfeit pills containing fentanyl
prosecutors also released surveillance
video showing Prince entering dr.
Michael Schulenburg clinic with his
friend Kirk Johnson the day before his
death schellenberg agreed to pay thirty
thousand dollars to settle a federal
civil case in which authorities allege
he wrote Prince's prescriptions out to
Johnson to protect the musician's
privacy Schellenberg's attorney says his
client denies any such liability and he
did not prescribe opiates to any patient
with the intention that they'd be given
to Prince because Prince was an
intensely private person
he was certainly assisted and enabled by
others to obtain some of these
medications Prince's cousin Charles
Smith says the family is very
disappointed no one is being held
responsible for his death somebody
helped take it take the brother out in
my opinion and you want somebody to pay
but somebody to pay for it whether you
accidentally did it or not
text messages between doctor Chelan Berg
and Johnson showed that the two were
concerned about the singer's well-being
Kirk Johnson's attorney says that he
denies any wrongdoing in his close
friends death and that the decision by
prosecutors to not file charges affirms
his innocence
John Jamie thank you